prince harry and meghan markle are
giving us a rare look at their son
archie
on thursday the duke and duchess of
sussex celebrated their son
archie's second birthday with the world
posting this photo
on the website for their archwell
foundation not only is the royal couple
giving a look at little archie playing
in nature
but they also have a special request in
honor of his birthday
asking everyone to join in advocating
for kovan 19 vaccine equity
and now et is learning more about why
harry and megan chose to highlight this
initiative on their son's special day
i think a lot of people were hoping for
a new picture of
archie um but the couple have decided
that this year they really wanted to put
the focus
on the vaccination campaign they are
asking people that want to wish archie a
happy birthday
if they're in a position to to make a
small donation as little as five dollars
to the vaccination campaign so that
people in developing areas can get
vaccinated
and the archworld foundation through
sponsorship will will match that
turn it into 20 and that will enable
four people to get a vaccine and
as harry and megan has said on archwell
their website they can think of no
better way
to celebrate archie's birthday than that
act of philanthropy so
no pictures but certainly some really
really good work that will be done
in archie's name but this isn't the
first time harry and megan have
advocated for the covet 19 vaccine
over the weekend the duke shared a
passionate speech at the vax live
concert benefit
encouraging world leaders to make sure
vaccines are accessible for all
in reality and especially with this
pandemic
when any suffer we all suffer
we must look beyond ourselves with
empathy and compassion for those we know
and those we don't we need to lift up
all of humanity and make sure that no
personal community
is left behind as for archie his second
birthday is not going unnoticed
especially by his royal family members
the royal family instagram account
posted a photo on behalf of queen
elizabeth archie's great grandmother
writing wishing archie mountbatten
windsor a very happy second birthday
harry's brother william and his wife
kate middleton also gave archie a shout
out sharing a photo from archie's
christening
harry's relationship with his brother
and sister-in-law has seemingly been on
the mend following the sussex's
explosive interview with oprah winfrey
in march
in april harry reunited with the royal
family at his grandfather
prince philip's funeral and according to
nickel archie's birthday has been
helpful in calming tension in the family
well it's archie's second
birthday so it's definitely a time for
any family differences to be
put aside and you know we know that
there have been family risks we know
that there have been fallouts but the
idea that
harry wouldn't speak to his family on a
date as important as his son's birthday
um it's just not going to happen in fact
nichols says there's even plans for a
virtual get-together
i understand that there were plans for a
zoom call i know the queen
is particularly keen to see archie and
today because of course
none of the family have seen him for
about 18 months now so they are missing
out on all those important milestones
and
i do know that when it comes to
birthdays and great efforts have been
made particularly
with the sussex um in in los angeles
for there to be some sort of a
connection with the family just an
opportunity to say hi
happy birthday
you